hey guys Justin and Carolyn here with a
GameSpot breakdown we're gonna be
talking about that Batman Arkham Knight
trailer that just came out and
apparently it's a gameplay trailer that
you saw quite a bit of not too long ago
alright so in the game when GDC rolled
around recently I went to a
behind-closed-doors
gameplay demo and pretty much everything
that's in this gameplay trailer is stuff
that I saw in that demo and so whether
the moniker of this being a gameplay
trailer is applicable or not you know we
can we can argue about that but but it
does reveal a lot of the things that I
saw at that demo so for instance the the
trailer begins with victim being
evacuated this is in response to like a
like a weapon of mass destruction level
threat that scarecrow has made so Gordon
I think orders the evacuation of a city
this is a convenient way I think for the
developers to not have to deal with
Gotham as a city with pedestrians
everywhere it you know it will again be
this kind of empty city like it has been
in previous Arkham games the only people
around are the criminals and thugs you
know we're gonna enjoy the absence of
you're not gonna have to worry about
Batman going up and punching pedestrians
in the face you don't get to do that
unfortunately so some other things that
this gameplay trailer reveals is the
fact that you can kind of sum in the
Batmobile to wherever you are you don't
have to go to it right it has an a
function where you can just summon it
you jump up in the air yeah you can jump
up in the air and just stylish Lee just
plop down to the cockpit the Batmobile
will do this really stylish thing or
just kind of swerves and skids right up
to where you are and you know conversely
into what the trailer also shows is that
you can eject right out of the Batmobile
and be immediately at like a gliding
altitude so you can just use that to
reach you know higher areas in the city
and it's just a really good looking game
as well like that people can't really
tell the difference between is this game
plan is it not it just not so good
absolutely it was definitely stunning
when I saw it I mean the imagery in the
does match up with my recollection of
how the game looked when it was being
played the only caveat is that when I
saw the demo and of course it's still
you know months out from release there
were definitely times when the game
performance chugged a bit so you know
whether it can maintain that level of
detail and they can get it to perform
the way they wanted to or you know it
may be a case where before the final
release we end up seeing the graphics
get downgraded a little bit so the game
can perform better who knows and the
game is called Arkham Knight which I
thought was referencing Batman himself
but apparently that's it that's a
character in the game yes
so so when Sarat rocks that he told me
and other members of the press that this
is a new character that that they have
created in collaboration with DC
specifically for this story however so
the Arkham Knight we don't see his face
he's in this armored you know suit and
so my feeling is that you know why I
have a character like that unless
there's gonna be a moment of reveal
where surprise it's a character that we
already know you know from the Batman's
lore and you know there's that there's
already except her in the Batman more
who's kind of served its function in the
past called the Red Hood where that
character has been different other
characters depending on the needs of the
story
who's the arkham knight gonna end up
being you know my there's a part of me
that really wants to say that because
the Joker has loomed so large in the
arkham mythology up to this point that
it's gonna end up being jim i I don't
know the Arkham Knights behavior doesn't
seem characteristic of the insanity that
we expected the Joker but there's at
least gonna be some big Joker connection
there and that's what my heart is
telling me oh there's got to be some
surprise character who's gonna be
someone who can take down Batman because
it's such a an indomitable guy their
turn this one's gonna come up point a
gun in his face that we assigned this
trailer the Joker in that I think that's
a good choice even though he has died in
this series of games that we played so
we're so we're meant to think at this
point you know I it wouldn't it all
surprise me if if that ends up to not be
the case and
the the Joker is alive and well somehow
in the Arkham universe as Arkham night
begins at one point in the trailer we
see or a cola so as she appears in this
game as a physical presence for the
first time she's not just a voice on the
bat headset in Arkham Knight she has her
an Oracle is the thing that tie is
everything in Gotham City together that
lets Batman know what's going on
basically in the entire Oracle is it you
know hooked into every computer system a
man in imaginable shetan provides Bruce
Wayne you know Bruce Wayne with whatever
information he needs so yeah she's she's
a very valuable resource and she has her
elaborate Clocktower hideout that you
visit in Arkham Knight which is
something from from the comics way if
there's also a moment in the trailer
where we see the Batmobile going up the
side of a cylindrical underground tunnel
this is part of the Riddler's challenges
in Arkham Knight the Riddler's
challenges now incorporate the Batmobile
there these kinds of obstacle courses
that seem to take place underground and
have you having to drive the Batmobile
really stylish Lee while also using its
computer systems to manipulate the
environment to bring platforms out and
lower barricades and that sort of thing
so driving isn't just gonna be a way to
get from point A to point B yes it's a
part of the game it really is they that
that was definitely the standout feature
of the gameplay demo that I saw the
Batmobile just looks really fun to drive
you know it looked like it had all of
these awesome capabilities as far as you
know driving up the sides of walls and
that sort of thing so so yeah they're
they're really pushing the Batmobile
hard as the central mechanic of Arkham
Knight at one point we see Batman
smashing a thugs face into an electrical
panel that's a new feature in the combat
if these sort of sleeping dogs ask
environmental attacks very cool and I
bet we'll see a lot more of this game at
the next months III where maybe we'll
finally get some hands-on time as well
so be sure to stay tuned to
you